well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they come in
in the next half hour or so we will see
what's making the headlines with the
consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce and the
associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire which
means tonight how did the chancellor do
in the budget doesn't it but we'll come
to your thoughts in just a moment
let's rattle through those front pages
first of all uh not surprisingly then
ft leading with today's budget statement
by rishi sunak
which the paper calls a spend now tax
later plan
the guardian with a similar headline
suggesting businesses
and middle income could field the
greatest strain
the times carries the headline highest
tax levels for 50 years the metro
doesn't yet seem to be sold on the
chancellor's proposals dubbing him
risky sunac the telegraph has a blunt
assessment they call the budget
sunac's five-year tax grab the express
says positively our recovery begins
today with the chancellor putting
britain
on a path to prosperity daily mail
leading with an unprecedented buckingham
palace investigation into
allegations that the duchess of sussex
bullied her staff her spokesperson
has denied the claims same story front
of the mirror with the headline all-out
war
at the palace and the daily star has its
own unique
take on the state of relationships
within the house of
windsor two stories then i guess andrew
p is kevin maguire here let's kick off
with the budget
andrew contain yourself uh daily
telegraph
um tax is the word making most of the
front pages
how will that go down in number 11
downey street andrew
well look this is always going to be an
incredibly difficult budget it's only
richie sooner second one
he seems to have been part of the
furniture political furniture for much
longer than that
and i think he had to walk a very
delicate tightrope and i think he
managed it rather well
we've got the worst debt we've ever had
um
currently we can afford it because not
it what in 2025 or something
um total debt will be 97
of our gdp 97 of our economy will be
built on debt
but 92 of that is owed by the bank of
england so
in a sense the government owes the money
to itself
but the worry is if interest rates go up
all his calculations go go by the board
but what he's done the first two years
it's like two budgets first two years
it's all about
kickstarting growth um that incredible
uh incentive for companies to invest
i think that's a really attractive
clever idea
what i forgot what they call it but um
if if you invest a lot of money in plant
and machinery
you'll get 100 yeah the deduction yeah
you get your taxi
so there's there's lots of really
eye-catching proposals in there
and the big policy the big tax rate big
tax raise is on
corporation tax now i quite like the
idea we were lowering our
corporation tax every year because i
quite like the idea that we
could become the singapore of europe it
was george osborne and david cameron's
pet policy
he's junk that so in two years time uh
uh
corporation tax soars from 19 to 25
but that still is the lowest in the g7
and it's still lower than france which
is 32
it's lower than germany it's lower than
a lot of the european union
it's way above ireland of course at
twelve and a half percent
but it's probably the most sellable to
the electorate
tax to increase because he's talking
about big companies
that pay that make huge profits so they
can pay more taxes
my disappointment with that though is so
that means companies that make profits
of more than quarter of a million a year
that's british companies those wretched
tax dodgers like amazon and google have
got away with it again
because they don't pay a lot of
corporation tax now and this won't
impact on them at all
we've had all the talk from successive
chances whether it was gordon brown or
alice
darling george osborne and now rishi
soon after he's going to hit these
guys with a big tax bill and yet again
they've got
clean away with it so the daily
telegraph chews over how much extra tax
you will pay
by 2026. this is mainly in terms of the
frozen thresholds on things like
income tax pensions tax allowance
inheritance tax capital gains tax and so
on
financial times focusing as you might
expect with the business newspaper on
that corporation tax
suggesting the increase from 19 to 25
will raise 17 billion pounds a year by
2025
but if you look at the times that sucks
it to the chancellor
the highest tax levels for 50 years now
you might say that's inevitable as he
did
to our economic senator ed conway
because of the pandemic but
for a chancellor like me she's seen it
that's a hard headline isn't it uh kevin
oh yeah uh look it wasn't inevitable it
was a political
and an economic choice and he's made
that
choice and you you asked about the
headlines across the papers
the telegraph talked about a tax grab
the times has got the
50 50 years he probably likes the
express which is just an extension of
the number 10 propaganda machine
uh he's probably relieved meghan
markle's on the front of the mirror and
the mail
because overall the headlines are very
very negative you might think they could
have been
even worse but they are negative
nonetheless and you'll be worried about
that because he's hugely ambitious for
himself and it's
way beyond the economy it's all about
whether he can get to
number 10. in fact that picture on the
front of the times looks very
prime ministerial he's in uh he's in uh
number 11 down in street i think that's
all previous chances but that is
that is always like a prime minister
walking up the stairs
with all the pictures of previous uh
prime ministers uh
around them he does that in part because
he's very very tall
he's uh he's about five foot six or
something
and they realize that when he stands
outside of the red box with his team
it just looks very very minute uh so
they
they've been cleverly got them on the
top stair to make it make them look
bigger as well
but now that that budget i just think
it's a a lot of big errors
including cutting public spending away
from covert because all these covert
spending
is time limited it's a three month
extension here
at six month extension there that will
go
but these tax risers are going to be
permanent including those
uh million plus people who will start
paying income tax for the first time
holding permanent permanent until 2026
because that's what it's frozen till
isn't it but yeah do
they're going to pay it more people on
very low incomes are going to be paying
income tax
you could have justified i think the
higher rate holding it around 50 000
you can arguably do that and corporation
tax is just very very sensible but but
andrew mentioned there's 25 billion
billion for investment the obvious
budget responsibility says that may not
generate growth
because companies have been sitting on a
huge
amount of money they couldn't spend to
invest during the pandemic
and i think there's one estimate 120
billion now
they're going to get 25 p for every
pound they spend it's just going to be
uh you know in the back pocket yeah i
mean that that's that favors the brave
doesn't it that policy and if you're
ready to invest right now which some
might be
then it's brilliant for you um but in
terms of the the
minimum tax threshold and to be fair
that's gone up massively hasn't he that
was a lib dem policy as part of the
the coalition government as i remember
back in 2010 so you could argue that's
really gone up in the last few years
and the guardian then spend now pay
later soon flags major tax rises
as the covert bill soars and these
things you say aren't there forever
six months on universal credit uh the uh
furlough
till the end of september because the
prediction for growth next year is
enormous isn't it
andrew this idea that people are sitting
on cash they haven't been able to spend
what does that mean politically then or
does it just mean that there's a sort of
bonanza for all next year
well it the the growth predictions are
extraordinary um
seven and a half percent next year which
is unprecedented and the office of
budget responsibility which is
independent
uh and has predicted that pre
that will be back to pre-prep
pre-pandemic levels
of uh growth and profitability
by the middle of 2022 that's six months
earlier
so that's a really positive sign now
everything is spread it's
he is really walking a tightrope um and
i think
i mean kevin's criticizing the budget i
think it's a very clever budget and i'd
like to see what labour would have done
differently
you know we've got this this help for
people who want to buy a home which is
great news
um uh people i know our tax thresholds
are being frozen
but look he's got to claw some of this
money back you can't just keep printing
money
what if you in in kevin mcguire's
dream socialist utopia but you've got to
get some money back and i think he's
doing it rather cleverly the worry is
um if inflation starts to rise which it
could
uh that then puts interest rates up if
interest rates go up one percent
that's a 25 billion pounds increase on
our debt repayment
that wipes out the money he's bringing
in from that huge increase
in corporation tax and who'd have
thought a tory chancellor
would be increasing corporation tax for
the first time
since the days of dennis healey it's the
first increase
it's extraordinary it's a very brave
gamble uh uh
say i'm a man who prefers that we cut
taxes cut taxes to promote growth
but we are in such a polished position i
think it's very courageous him to do it
before you butt in i just want
yeah go on then quickly then go i'm old
enough to uh
when um andrew and the conservator
argue that corporation tax rises when
they were proposed by labor would be
terrible it would cost the treasury
money because cutting it
made more money no it didn't that lie
has now
been nailed and it will raise 79 billion
that was given to companies again as a
as a backhander but when we go on about
growth
you've got to remember there's gonna be
three percent uh permanent scarring now
that's about 60 billion
gone and the growth after the little
bounce back
next year i think is it 1.7 1.6
1.7 is forecast it's gone down from five
and a half to four this year
they're pretty feeble figures so he's
not some chancellor overseeing some
economic miracle his
covert spending will fall when
covid is pushed just okay
i'm i'm going to interrupt you because
there was a thought
yeah while we look at the the metro
which also talks about risky sunac
the idea that he's gambled 65 billion
pounds extra on spending
on this quick recovery for this pandemic
and there was a thought that you had
that
really they're pushing for an early
election because they they want this
year of glowing growth
and and then and then you know reap the
rewards i think he's
i think it's entirely plausible they'll
get rid of that stupid fixed term
parliament
which we should never have had anyway
madness from the lib dems that david
cameron signed up to
i think it's entirely possible they go
for it in 2023
but have had an enormous year of growth
and boom and boom
next year it will the economy the growth
will start slowing down in 2023
it'd be a very good time and it will be
the old thing people will look
when economies are in trouble they look
to tories to rescue them there's a poll
out today on is showing
60 approval for the budget and 66
approval for rishi zunak if they'd ask
if they want to approve the shadow
chance that they'd have said
who okay very quickly what's his name
brenda from bristol should look away now
because i think we should have
a general election uh so much sooner
because the pandemic
don't be ridiculous has changed
everything all the election promises and
the manifestos
that were stood on in 2019 although
labour said they'd
cut uh sorry raised corporation taxes
now the tories doing it but they've all
gone
so i think you should put the forward
the competing
views of how you progress and how you
build back
better in britain put them to people and
let
it oh we're running over as ever no i've
got time i've got time to hear you i've
got too much to pack in in the second
half as you know yes exactly
zip it uh lock it put it in your pocket
but that's for swearing we won't do that
just yet
uh plenty more from them in just a
moment a political friendship gone south
we'll discuss nicola sturgeon's
testimony in the summit affair that's
[Music]
only about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
a lot of action going on
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin
and very frail her arms look at her arms
i can
put my entire hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
and once it takes out it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it out
the world's largest folds now down to a
track in places
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
[Music]
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back watching the press preview
with me now andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire
uh plenty still to talk about not least
what happened north of the border today
kevin
a long day of evidence being given by
the first minister there nicholas
sturgeon
yeah and uh the budget got in the way of
my uh viewing of it uh i found it
utterly
gripping but nicola sturgeon uh there
the metro that's page seven to serve to
clear my
plot to get salmon she'd be pleased the
budget was there because
certainly in the london base papers it's
pushed a way
inside she was a bit flustered and
flummoxed that time but i
thought other times she just recovered
her her authority and just plowed on she
was held by the snp
convener the chair of the the committee
who uh if anyone
seemed to be giving her a tough time
would have would intervene it looked to
me as a viewer
um but now there we are she said there
will absolutely no plot uh i was honest
all the way through
uh i'm not sure about that uh but we'll
see i think if she's going to survive
isn't it and perhaps it's right that she
survives and
it's the scottish people at the election
in may who
decide whether they want her to be first
minister whether the snp
get a majority put it over to them yeah
um we're going to move on if you don't
mind andrea unless you've got something
to say about that on to the uh well i'm
just going to say very briefly on that
there's an independent adjudicator
working behind the scenes looking at all
the papers who could actually do far
more damage to nicolas sturgeon
than that hearing today because i agree
with maguire nobody landed there was no
killer blow
the real problem for her is if that the
independent inquiry says that that court
case should not have happened
and she then abused her position because
if you
misuse public money that's a breed of
the minister of goats she could be in
trouble on that basis
we've got less than a minute now for you
to do your front page daily mail and the
front page of the daily mirror which is
about
megan and the bullying allegations at
the palace
well briefly there's no denial now that
this uh allegations of bullying were
made when megan was
uh still within the royal household uh
no denial that that she's denied the
bullying happened but there's no denial
that the allegations were made against
her what's interesting is the palace
have moved it forward and they're now
going to say
they're going to talk to all those
people the two people who apparently
were forced out
any other staff who worked there so um
this story as we say in the trade has
got legs and it looks if
half of it's true it's very unpleasant
for about meghan markle
okay and obviously all eyes on the oprah
winfrey
interview overnight sunday night uh to
be broadcast
yeah well we will certainly see and
watch what happens with that
um lovely to see you both we will see
for more at half past eleven thank you
very much
indeed and uh just a reminder of what's
coming up in the next hour here on sky
news we will
pour over all those details of the
budget coming up in sky news
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to safety
rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
you